ก็
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดี
ค่ะครูฝาสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนนะคะคุณป้าวัน
นี้เราพบกันที่ที่ไหนคะเนี่ย
เรียนภาษาไทยกับเราที่ไหนคะที่ไหนที่ไหน
ที่บ้านที่บ้านบ้านบ้านบ้าน
สระแนวไหนคะเสร็จแล้วไหน Channel คอมเพลง
เซเบอร์ไทยค่ะนะคะค่ะคลิปวันนี้วันนี้วัน
อะไรคะครูฟ้าเดี๋ยวเราเขียนวันกันก่อน
เนาะ
วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะวัน
พฤหัสบดีราคาปุ๋ย
ชาวม.คเป็นภาษาไทยทุกที
วันพฤหัสบดีนะคะอ่ะอ่า
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 16 ค่ะงั้นที่ 16
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมปีพต
ตเท่าไหร่คะปีพศ 2564
2564 พี่ข้อศ.เท่าไหร่คะมีข้อสส 2021
ค่ะวันนี้นะคะวันพฤหัสบดีวันที่ 16 เดือน
ธันวาคมปีพ.ศ
2506  14 ปีค.ศ 2000  21 นะคะแล้วก็
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันพุธ
ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันพุธนะคะวันที่เท่าไหร่
คะวันที่ 15 วันที่ 15 นะคะเดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
ธันวาคม 5 ค่ะวันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีเมื่อวาน
นี้วันพุธพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วัน
ศุกร์ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันศุกร์นะคะวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่ 17 วันที่ 17 นะคะครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันที่ 16
นี่
ลอตเตอรี่
ที่อะไรวันที่ 16 ลอตเตอรี่ครูเองลืม
คิดได้เอ้อ 16 ลอตเตอรี่อีกซื้อลอตเตอรี่
ไหมซื้อไม่ได้ซื้อไม่ได้ซื้อ
โอเคไม่เป็นไรครูฟ้าวันนี้ไม่ซื้อ
ลอตเตอรี่ไม่เป็นไรเพราะครูเองอ่ะกูฟ้า
เดี๋ยวกูอีกนี้ก่อนนะครับลบ
อีกรอบลบ
ๆวันที่ 20 ศวันจันทร์นะคะ
วันจันทร์
ที่ 13
ธันวาคม
2011 คู่เด็ดครูเอนะคะภูฟ้าจากกรุงเทพฯ
จากกรุงเทพฯคู๋ไปที่จังหวัดชลบุรี
มีบ้าน
บ้านคุณพ่อแม่แล้วก็
พี่สาว
พี่ชาย
ครูเอ๋
น้องชาย
บ้าคุณพ่อคุณพ่อผู้เสียชีวิตแล้วพี่ชาย
เสียชีวิตแล้วงานคุณแม่กับพี่สาวอยู่ที่
บ้านที่ชลบุรี
และที่บ้านที่ชลบุรีน่ะมีต้นมีต้นมะพร้าว
ก็มะพร้าวหรอมีต้นมะพร้าวมีต้นกล้วย
[เพลง]
กินกล้วยกล้วยจะเหมือนไหม
โอเคเดี๋ยวนักเรียนจะเห็นกล้วยนะคะใจเย็น
แม่มีต้นไม้เยอะๆ
คราวนี้คลิปนี้โอเคก็เลยมีขัดกับผลไม้
วู่บางอย่างจากชลบุรีเอามาให้นักเรียนดู
ค่ะชุดจริงหรอเอ๋อยากดูกินได้ไหม ahh ก็
กินได้ครูเอ๋กินอ้าวกูปะทะไม่ได้กินครู
เอ๋กินอ่ะ
เดี๋ยวให้ครูฟ้าดูนะคะเดี๋ยวคุณเอ๋บอกว่า
มีอะไรบ้างนางแล้วคิดเองเป็นอะไรนะคะมี
ผักกับผลไม้นะคะอันที่เป็นไว้แล้วกันค่ะ
ครูฟ้าอะไรคะอันนี้รวยค่ะ
ครูฟ้าครูอ๋อยเป็นผักหรือผลไม้คะ
กล้วยเป็น
ผลไม้ค่ะกล้วยเป็นผลไม้อ๋อกล้วยครูเอ๋มี
กล้วยทั้งหมดเพราะเป็น
1  1 ลูกหนึ่งหวี 1 เครือ
เอมมีกล้วยทั้งหมด
ท่าเรือไหม 1v หวี A มีกล้วยหนึ่งหวีนะคะ
อาแล้วก็มีลูกกล้วยอ่ะคู่ฟ้านับไม่มีลูก
อ่ะคู๋ไหน 1  2  3  1  2  3  4  5  6  7
8  9
1 ลูก 1  2  3  4  4  5  5  6  7  8  9
มี 9 ลูกจริงๆมีสิทธิ์น่า
กินหนึ่ง
[เพลง]
กูเอมิกล้วยนะคะกลัวยนี้เป็นที่ว่ากล้วย
เล็บกล้วยเล็บมือนาง
ชนะกล้วยหมื่นนางมาเป็นกล้วยเด็กเล็ก
พูดกล้วยโอเค
สีอะไรนะคะกูหมา
หลังรวยคะสีเหลืองคะ 5 รวยเป็นผลไม้นะคะ
กูเองว่าก่อนนะคะครูมาวางไวน์ก็ไม่
ต่อไป
กู้พี่เอ๋มีอันนี้ค่ะครูฟ้า
เอาใหญ่ๆ
มีมีกะละมัง
แต่ว่ามีถุงละสิด้วยเอ้ยสีที่ตัวเอง
อันนี้คืออะไรหุ้ยมะละกอ
มะละกอครูพระมาก
มาละกอเป็นผักหรือผลไม้
มะละกอเป็นเป็นคุณละไม้
มะละกอถ้ามะละกอสีส้มเนาะเป็นผลไม้
แล้วว่าลาก่อนสีเขียว
เป็นผักอ่ะถ้า
งง
ใช่ไหมคะมาแล้วก็อันนี้เรียกว่าเราก่อน
สุขอันนี้กินโอเคถ้ามานั่งก่อนสีเขียว
ต้องไปทำอาหาร
ก็พูดว่าเป็นผัดและกอเป็นลูกครึ่งเนาะลูก
ครึ่งแปดห้าสีเหลืองสีส้มอันนี้คือเป็น
ผลไม้
50 เขียวเป็นผัก
[เพลง]
อะไรนะคะใหญ่มากได้เว้ยอะไรมากบ้านคุณแม่
แม่มีต้นต้นนะคะมะละกอ 3 ต้นเปล่าต้นเลย
หรอต้น
ลูกมากๆ
เก็บนะคะเก็บเลยสีอันนี้มะละกอสุกนะคะคะ
มะละกอสุกเป็นผลไม้กินให้วางก่อนนะคะได้
ตัวเองนี่เอง
อะไรคะมีอะไรอีก
อันนี้
อันนี้คืออะไรคะคุณเอ๋
ลำไย
ลำไยลำไย
มีมีกลิ่นมีกลิ่นเนาะเก่งหญิงน่านก้าน
กิ่งที่นี่ก้านที่นี่โอเคกิ่งก้านแล้วก็
มีลูกลูกลำไยรวมกันเป็นหนึ่งพวงหนึ่งมีลำ
อย่างใน 5 ผัวถือมา 1 พวงนะคะแล้วมีกี่
ลูกคะ 1 พวง 1 โทรหาคะช่วงนี้มี 1  2  3
4  5  6  7  8
เอางูอ้าวลูกมี 9 รูปเท่ากับ
รวย
เท่าเท่ากันเลยเท่ากันเลยนะคะลำไย 1 พวง
พวงนี้มี 9 ลูกบางที 10 ลูกบางที 15 โอเค
นะลำไยปรึกสีอะไรคะครูฟ้าลำไยสีน้ำตาลค่ะ
เอ๋น้ำตาลครูฟ้า
ลำไยเป็นผักหรือผลไม้
ลำไยเป็น
ผลไม้หักค่าลำไยเป็นผลไม้นะคะ
ลำใหญ่ไหมคะชอบปลาชอบลำใหญ่ข้าวไม่คุยอีก
เก็บ
คู่ฟ้ากูเองไม่ได้อยู่ใกล้กันให้
ก็ไม่ได้ไม่ได้
ร้านอามามาสุขุมวิท 52 คู๋ให้
ไม่ไกลมัน
เอาไปค่ะครูฟ้ามีอีก
วิธีอ่า
อันนี้คืออะไรคะคุณเอ๋มาเห็นไหมอ่ะหิน
โอเคองุ่นค่ะองุ่นอันหมดเอาอันนี้เรียก
เป็นอะไรอะไรนะคะองุ่นองุ่นองุ่นจึงสี
อะไรอ่ะสีม่วงสีม่วงง่วงเรื่องจนดำเด็ด 1
ไม่รู้จะจ่าย
กินไหมเห็นไหมบีบม่วงหรือดำม่วงม่วงกัน
เรา
มากต้องเห็นแสงอะไรไม่ใช่สีม่วงหะม่วงนะ
คะ
นักม่วง
ง่วงอ่ะ
ครูฟังนะคะองุ่นอันนี้โอเคไม่นับนะคะ
องุ่น 1 บ่วงอะใหญ่มากก็มีมีลูกเยอะมัน
รู้ไงโอ้โหเยอะอ่ะอยากให้น้ำใช่ไหมคะ
ค่ะสิ 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  9  10  11
12  13  14  15  16  17  18  19  20  21
12  13  14  15 โอเค 50
ไม่รู้ไม่นับนะอันนี้เรียกว่าองุ่น 1 ควร
นะคะองุ่นเป็นผักหรือผลไม้คะ
องุ่นเป็นผลไม้ค่ะเป็นผลไม้ในไทยเนาะหนัง
ไทยคนไทยดูคลิปผลไม้นะคะ
เห็นว่างคุยเก็บนะคะ
อีกผู้ฟ้าเอมี่อะไร
องุ่นกับลำไยเป็นพวงเหมือนกันเนาะ
ลำไย 1 นั่น 1 พวงองุ่น 1 พวงนะคะ
ลำไยกับองุ่นเป็นพวงนะคะผู้ว่างใช่
ก็มีไอค่ะ
อันนี้คืออะไรคะครูเอ๋อันนี้คือส้ม
ส้มก็ 1 ลูก 1 ลูก
ส้มส้มสีอะไรอ่ะฟ้าส้มสีเขียวกับสีผิด
ห้องพักเก้าอี้สีเขียวอันนี้สีส้มราคาสี
ส้มกอล์ฟกลมๆหนึ่งลูกนะคะ
5r ครูฟ้าส้มเป็นผักหรือผลไม้
ซ่อมเป็นผลไม้ค่ะส้มเป็นผลไม้เก่งมากค่ะ
ส้มเป็นผลไม้
อะไรเข้าเอกซ้อมไง
ซ่อมมือซ้ายส้มมือขวาต้มไหมเหมือนไหม
เหมือนมากนักเรียนคิดส้มไหม
สงฆ์ซ่อมหรือไม่ใช่ส้ม
อันนี้ไม่ใช่ส้มครูฟ้าอ้าวไม่ใช่ส้มแล้ว
คืออะไรคือมะนาว
หัวหนาวเอากินข้าวนะฮะมะนาวแต่ว่ามะนาว
ของครูเอ๋ลูกใหญ่
อยากก่อนต้องสีเขียว
อยู่ที่บ้าน 1 วัน 2 วัน 3 วัน 4 วัน 5
วัน 6 วัน 7 วัน 8 วัน 9 วัน 10 วัน
เปลี่ยน
สีเป็นสีเหลืองซีรีส์เรื่องเอา
[เพลง]
ส้มหวานมะนาวเปรี้ยว
มะนาวเป็นผักหรือผลไม้คะ
มะนาวเป็นสิ้นไปให้เป็นผักนานทำให้ผลไม้
นะใช่มะนาวมะนาวเป็นผัก a หันให้ดูดีกว่า
มะนาวหนาว
เลยหรอ
หันมะนาวแต่อันอื่นไม่ห่างนะฮะอ่ะอ่าหั่น
ผักวีหันนี่
มะนาว
มะนาวชิมนะไงก็พูดไม่แก้วน้ำ
เลี้ยงแล้วก็บีบมะนาวใส่
บีบสระบีบมะนาวใส
ดื่มน้ำ
เที่ยว
เปรี้ยว
เปรี้ยวมาก
โอเคมะนาวเป็นผักส้มเป็นอะไรนะคะต้มเป็น
ผลไม้ค่ะมะนาว
มะนาวเป็นผักส้มเป็นผลไม้นะคะอะไรคะอะไร
อีกแม่ตัวเองมีอีกแต่ละเลยเดี๋ยวนะโอเคมี
อะไรดี
อันนี้ดีกว่า
อันนี้คืออะไรล่ะครูเอ๋
พุทรา
[เพลง]
อาหารพุทราพุทราลูกใหญ่มากบางคนพูดพุทรา
นมสด
ทำไมพูดผู้ชายหนุ่มสดทุกสานะคะ
R เป็นผักหรือผลไม้คะ
พุทราเป็นผลไม้ค่ะเป็นผลไม้นะคะว่างพุทรา
อ่าไม่ใช่ผักเป็นผลไม้และดูแล้วคล้ายๆ
แอปเปิ้ลเนาะซึ่งคล้ายๆแอปเปิ้ลเพราะว่า
สีเขียวใช่ไหมลายสีเขียวนะคะสีเขียวใครๆ
แอปเปิ้ลอ่ะมี
อะไหล่ ok นะเดี๋ยวคลิปหน้าหันแล้วชิมให้
ดู
โง่โง่หน้า
มีผู้ชายแล้วคุยมีอะไรอีกอ่ะ
[เพลง]
ครูฟ้าสีเขียวยาวๆรู้จักนี่คือคืออะไรคะ
พี่เอ๋นี่คือถั่ว Who
ถั่วพูถั่วพู
ถั่วพูคู่ฟ้ารู้ไหมว่าถั่วพูเป็นผักหรือ
ผลไม้
ถั่วพลูเป็นผักค่ะใช่ค่ะรวมกูเป็นผักค่ะ
กินได้เลยกินให้เลยอ่ะ
จะ
กลับๆจุ๊บๆ
ทำไมกูอีกต้องกินก็คือ
ผู้ว่าชอบกินถูกกูทักชอบเหรอตายตัวเองมี
เยอะๆฟ้าร้องถั่วกูมีหนึ่งถุงใหญ่หมู
มาๆมาบ้านเอ๋
ได้ค่ะ
แฟนชอบถั่ว
ไปค่ะเอาไปอะไรคะกูเอ๋อะไร
แอปเปิ้ลดุกที่นี่เหมือนเดี๋ยวเปิ้ลเนาะ
เออ
ใช่ไหมไม่ใช่
ไม่ใช่แอปเปิ้ลเราคืออะไรอ่ะ
คือมะเขือเทศ
มะเขือเทศใช่ค่ะมี
มะเขือเทศ
1 รูป 5  1 ลูกลูกใหญ่ 1 รูปเออสีอะไรคะ
สีแดงค่ะแดงถ้าตรงนี้ล่ะจะมิสีส้ม
แดงๆส้มๆนะคะ
มะเขือเทศเป็นผักหรือผลไม้คะมะเขือเทศ
เป็นเป็นอะไร
ผัก
คนไทยคิดเป็นผักนะ
คนไหนคลิป
[เพลง]
นักเรียนคลิปผักหรือผลไม้เนาะ
ไม่อร่อยอร่อย
ครูฟ้าไม่ชอบ
เชยไม่ชอบคือก็โอเคของฟ้าเฉยๆกินได้นะก็
ได้นะคะแต่คู่ ami อันนี้อีกค่ะคือฟ้า
นี่คืออะไรมะเขือเทศอ้าวทำไมเล็ก
มะเขือเทศมีมากๆมีมะเขือเทศอ่ะใหญ่แล้วก็
มีมะเขือเทศใหญ่มากแล้วก็มีเมื่อเกิดเพศ
และแล้วก็มีไม่เสียเทศเล็กมากๆมีวันเกิด
เทศสีเหลืองด้วย
หลายไซส์เลยอะไรไซด์ไลน์ชื่อนะคะแล้วก็
อันนี้เราเรียกว่าเมื่อเขือเทศสีดา
แล้วก็มีเล็กๆมะเขือเทศมะเขือเทศมะเขือ
เทศมาเปิดที่มากๆครูเอ๋ลืมชื่อก็พูดว่า
เขือเทศลูกใหญ่นวดเขือเทศลูกเล็ก
เวลาเดินดูก็โอเคมะเขือเทศชายมะเขือเทศมี
มากๆ
คุณครูฟ้าไม่ชอบ
อยู่เฉยๆค่ะอุบายชอบดื่มน้ำมะเขือเทศออ
ออออร่อยกว่าอันนี้ก็เป็นมะเขือเทศนะคะ
มะเขือเทศอันนี้สำหรับใส่อาหารไทย
อันนี้อาหารไทยมะเขือเทศอันนี้สำหรับสลัด
2 สลัดนะคะ
[เพลง]
มีอะไรอีกเดี๋ยวกู ei อีกไหมจ๊ะเอ๋มีอีก
กูฟ้า
ไหน
รอเดี๋ยว
หายเหมีอะไรคะนักเรียนผัดหรือผลไม้
ไม่ว่างกูบาร์บี้ได้ไหมไม่ได้
ป่า
วิธีอะไรอยากเว้น
มะพร้าว
อันนี้คือมะพร้าวนะคะมาดีแล้วค่ะ
มะพร้าวสีเขียวเป็นเขียวเราก็จะพูดว่า
มะพร้าวอ่อนมะพร้าวอ่อนคะไม่เห็นสีน้ำตาล
น้ำตาลใช่มะอันนี้เป็นไม้ไม้สีน้ำตาล
สีน้ำตาลก็จะเป็นมะพร้าวแก่
มะพร้าวอ่อนมะพร้าวอ่อนเป็น
กินอะไรอ่ะเป็นผักหรือเป็นผลไม้เป็นผลไม้
เอาเป็นผลไม้นะผลไม้แม่แล้วนักเรียนคิด
เป็นผักเป็นผลไม้
ไม่รู้
ไม่รู้อันนี้คนไทยคิดเป็นผลไม้นะคะมะเขือ
เทศคนไทยคิดเป็นผักอ.
พร้าวเป็นผลไม้
1 ลูกใหญ่มากครูเอ๋มากในมากนั้น
เขียวนะคะคุณสาย
ครูฟ้าเดี๋ยวเรามาดูว่าวันเนี้ยมีผักกับ
ผลไม้อะไรบ้างอีกหนึ่งครั้งนะคะโอเคได้
เลยค่ะพี่เอ๋
ราคาก็เค้กกล้วยเป็นอะไรนะคะด้วยเป็นหวี
ค่ะกล้วยหนึ่งหวีนะคะเป็นผักหรือผลไม้นะ
กล้วยเป็นผลไม้
[เพลง]
รักพอเป็นอะไรคะมะละกอเป็นผลไม้ค่ะมะละกอ
สุกนะคะเป็นผลไม้มาหาเราก็มีอะไรอีก
มะเขือเทศเป็นอะไรนะคะมะเขือเทศเป็นผัก
เลยค่ะเสร็จให้เป็นภาษานะคะโอเค
ลำไยเป็นเป็นอะไรคะเป็นพระลำบนร้ายลำไย
เป็นผลไม้ลำไยเป็นผลไม้ในเป็นผลไม้ส้ม
เป็นผักหรือผลไม้คะห้องเป็นผลไม้ค่ะพร้อม
เป็นผลไม้
เกิดเทศมะเขือที่เป็นผักเป็นแผ่นนะคะ
มะนาว
เป็นผักหรือผลไม้
มะนาวเป็นผักมะนาวเป็นค่ะนะคะอันงูนเป็น
ผักหรือผลไม้
องุ่นเป็นผลไม้ค่ะ
พุทราเป็นผักหรือผลไม้
พุทราเป็นผลไม้ค่ะเป็นผลไม้ดอกไม้
ยางถั่วพู
ถั่วพลูเป็นผักเป็นผักนะคะหมดลำใจกูอ่ะ
พูดหรือยังลำไยลำไยเป็นบะหมี่หรือผลไม้
ลำไยเป็นผลไม้ค่ะ 5 แล้วก็มุกมะพร้าวอ่อน
เป็นผักหรือผลไม้คะมะพร้าวอ่อนเป็นผลไม้
ค่ะมะพร้าวอ่อนเป็นผลไม้
รู้ฟ้าชอบกินอะไรคะ
ที่ครูเอ๋มีที่เคยมีตอนนี้โหเยอะๆ
มั้ยชอบอ่ะกูฟ้าครับกรวยนะคะชอบกินตัว
ถ้วยชอบกินซองไหมคะ
ชอบมากชอบทรง
กินลำไยอีก
อะไรนะ
คุณบายกูบ้านชอบลำไยไหม
คุณฟ้าชอบลำไยค่ะหน้า
ลำไยนะคะ
ฟ้าชอบองุ่นไหมคะลูกฟ้าชอบองุ่นค่ะน้อง
องุ่นนะคะฟ้าชอบพูด 3 ไหมคะ
ไม่เคยกินขอกูพักไม่เคยกินนะคะเคยกินฟ้า
ไม่ชอบมะเขือเทศ
ไม่ชอบมะเขือที่ค่ะมะนาวชอบไหมคะ
มะนาว
โอเคมะนาว OK ถ้าชอบมันน่ะเขามะละกอโอ้
ๆเดี๋ยวคุยยกวันนี้กลัวมะละกอนตก
[เพลง]
ตกไม่โอเคมาละกอชอบไปคะ
มะละกอก็ชอบค่ะนะคะ
กับมะนาวกินด้วยจัง
อร่อยคะอร่อยค่ะวันนี้หยุดวันนี้ก็หมด
เวลานะเรียนก็รู้จักขัดแล้วก็ก็รู้จัก
ผลไม้
ผลไม้บางอย่างอย่างมะละกอสุกก็เป็นผลไม้
ถ้าสีเขียวเป็นค่ะมางั้นแม่ก็มีวันนี้ก็
มีอ่ะค่ะกับผลไม้นะคะให้นักเรียนนักเรียน
ชอบอะไรไม่รู้เนาะให้ก็นั่งเล่นคอมเม้น
บอกได้นะคะชอบมะละกอไหมชอบกล้วยไหมหรือ
ไม่ชอบมะเขือเทศเหมือนกูฟ้าหรือเปล่า
คอมเม้นท์บอกได้ค่ะนักเรียนและนักเรียนก็
บอกครูด้วยนะคะครูสงสัยมะนาวผักและผลไม้
อ่าคนไทยคิดผักนักเรียนคิดผักหรือผลไม้
มะเขือเทศเป็นผักหรือผลไม้
คอมเม้นท์บอกครูนะคะนักเรียนคิดว่าเป็น
ผักเหมือนคนไทยคิดไหมนะคะ
สำหรับคลิปนี้ครูเอ๋กับครูฟ้า
ค่ะบ๊ายบาย
ก่อนก่อนไปอย่าลืมอะไรครับครูฟ้าอย่าลืม
กด like กด Share กด Subscribe ขอให้นัก
เรียนมี ok แล้วเจอกันวีดีโอหน้าค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะสาธิตค่าบ๊ายบาย